new information about the Omicron covet
variants spreading rapidly across the
country in the last three days more than
671 thousand new cases have been
reported in the U.S and it could be
weeks before the numbers start to fall
but there is some potential good news a
new pill has been authorized to treat
covet in the U.S Nancy Chen has details
on that and why hospitalizations have
not increased sharply so far Nancy good
morning
Nate good morning to you new research
from several universities overseas shows
that omicon cases tend to be less severe
but Health officials are still
anticipating a spike in hospitalizations
across the country several hospitals are
already overwhelmed and in the New York
area nearly 20 urgent cares temporarily
closed yesterday because of staffing
issues
the sheer number of infection will cause
an overwhelming for most of our
hospitals some hospitals are already
there the ICU in Michigan's Beaumont
Dearborn hospital is at 98 capacity the
coronavirus accounts for most of those
cases what is the fear of what could
happen it's really the unknown
um we are in a perfect storm Mary Allen
coaches roulard is the chief nursing
officer
she's now working alongside a team of
U.S military members sent by the
government to help with Staff Inc one
thing Health officials say could help
Hospital Staffing shortages shortened
isolation times after exposure if you
are vaccinated and if you are boosted
and you get infected the virus may not
be staying with you for a longer time
for 10 days and we need you to come back
to work
Federal officials tell CBS News the CDC
will likely issue new guidance for
health care workers about isolating
after testing positive potentially
lowering the amount of time required to
five to seven days instead of 10 days
that guidance May ultimately be expanded
to a larger audience we got good news
today in a major milestone in the fight
against covet on Wednesday the FDA
authorized the first antiviral at-home
pill to treat the virus the agency found
Pfizer's five-day series of 30 pills
significantly reduced the risk of
hospitalization for those at risk of
serious illness it almost certainly will
be a physician writing a prescription
for someone who within the first three
days of notable symptoms of covid and is
in a high risk group to get it
now the White House does warn those
antiviral pills won't be widely
available for months and that the pills
are not a substitute for the vaccine
they only help after getting coronavirus
but with just two days left until
Christmas Gale Health officials are
reminding everyone to take those
precautions including wearing masks and
getting tested
and we can all do that Nancy thank you
very much